good to see you glaze your buddy how are
you I'm great Jay Glazer at Jay Glazer
on Twitter he as we all know mr. off NFL
on Fox information man as well as UFC
we'll hit on that Bellator Bellator
different-different did I jump
I don't know that Boston streams across
the street and you're part of NFL
Network's Fox's coverage of the draft
yep doing Wednesday and Thursday for
them then I'm hosting radio for the
crowd was them watch them it's for us
it's a family big families pollinating
oh like Thursday Night Football
no that's right right you know and I
usually don't schedule but I did see a
schedule for Fox's Thursday night man
you're like I am loving are you part of
that coverage I don't know yet nobody
knows anything yeah so out so we know
that's true inside I'm outside we know
that strays hosting the show I know that
we're just gonna mix in the $20,000
pyramid get Stephanopoulos in there too
I mean just cross all of the Dick Clark
time career that he's creating for him
so you know what's so funny too because
now obviously you're going around and
people who are like Michael's so big
people like he played in the head of
health isn't that amazing it's
unbelievable and he not only played he
hasn't felt you he was a bad violent
individual and people I mean you know I
said in the Hall of Fame speech and
don't let the gap and smile fool you but
he was my very very first friend ever
had in this business
93 covering the Giants and I had
probably hard for you to imagine but and
really get along with the other
reporters I was you know what exactly
quiet and Michael got drafts to replace
Lawrence Taylor and Lawrence Taylor is
still there I mean with Enys you know
got a gap II he's got bad teeth he's
from Germany had everything against him
so he and Isaac laughs on each other
right he and I just latched on each
other and I didn't have enough money
back then I was making like 9 grand a
year working right New York posting and
they were really paying and like a
little New York one TV and while uh for
450 bucks a year so I could afford bus
fare to giant Stadium every day but I
couldn't afford it back so I made
Strahan drive me into city every single
day for like six or seven years so I owe
him like twenty eight thousand dollars
in Lincoln Tunnel fare and then I was
like you know like having treatment yeah
and I would stand outside a locker room
to be like hey so many send people you
know like go like I got a date I got a
go any be like right yeah you kidding me
oh myit's you're killing my schedule you
could say that the only football player
that's had a more transformative post
career television career Gifford I mean
is he in that ring sorry no no obviously
more new stations and strength no but
obviously what he was having in pop
culture before the double murders but no
it was strange different right no that's
like Gifford doing Monday Night Football
and get for doing what he did while he
was playing also I mean that's what he's
doing now I think Michael end up owning
a team I think Michael really I do I
think like he constantly and it's
amazing he constantly pushes himself he
looks for new challenges with things
that have never been done before that's
the thing that that kind of
differentiates him with everybody else
he looks for things that just haven't
been done and he's like why not I'm
gonna go for it and he he will outwork
the world until he gets it done what do
you think Peyton Manning's gonna do
because what let's put it this way yeah
report on your own shop how real was the
report it well no no no so you report on
your own shop right now huh how real
we're going yes no no I know they were
talking I don't think the money thing
was was I'd be surprised about that okay
what do you think Peyton's gonna do here
it's pretty interesting because I
thought Payton I thought by now he would
have gotten the Elway Lynch the route
and run a team or more like a route yeah
and I thought it would been a big
franchise I thought he would have gone
somewhere I mean has he had an
opportunity even cause I think teams
have talked to him reached out but again
I think he's just you know retirements a
fun thing
yeah I'm assuming I don't know that we
have you know we both have a million
jobs but um you know if he when you have
your free time yeah and you have all
it's time to go play golf and do
whatever you wanna do and also and
you're gonna have to go put a suit and
tie every day and change your lifestyle
I think you can kind of go home I am I
gonna go do that so I know I I don't
think Payton knows what he wants to do
cuz Thursday Night Football would have
been an opportunity for her guy what am
i great it would have been great for I
think they're gonna be great at it I
think good anything he wants to do also
that's true yeah and I think he's I
think he's having fun just kind of
cherry picking whatever he wants to do
Jay Glazer here on the Rich Eisen show
all right do you know what the Cleveland
Browns are gonna do right now taking on
Bronson with the Cleveland Browns the
Cleveland Browns don't know what the
country or if it happens right it's rare
when a team is kind of really this
locked in right now the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers they were locked in on on
Jameis Winston in October
despite anything you ever heard after
that I am Telling You they were locked
in on him on October nothing ever
changed but there are teams that the
week of it this is the most incredible
thing about the draft right they've had
these guys change their mind the day of
the draft you had 364 days right to get
your opinion and it changes so what I do
is I wait really to start them bought
Barney guys with calls until this week
like talk to a team this morning said
okay we got a lot of grades done yeah
your cranes done
you got five days left like now you get
your grades done and now this weekend
we'll assemble our board so when they
assemble their board then they start
arguing again and the things that change
their mind
there was a quarterback last year it was
last on a team board of the top
quarterbacks yes it was Kaiser
and then Kaiser went in and met with
them again and he was the head coach and
all said head coach is like no he's my
top guy my board it was like you for 51
weeks and plugs you adela sudden in one
interview he went through the ceiling
again and the GM called said hey you but
he knew I was close to the head coaches
like you got to talk him back off
because it's you know all sudden he just
got he fell in love over one interview
there was the Dallas Cowboys they're
gonna draft Shawne Merriman with their
first round their first picked years ago
and Parcells and the morning of they
changed their mind like the Morehead it
was all Shawne Merriman in the morning
up they change it to the markets where a
couple hours before Merriman will tell
you that yep he will tell you that he
thought he had the star on the side of
his helmet and if story ripped the knob
off that's it
so like well go back to strand where he
had a count of the Cowboys I think has
the 38th pick in the draft that year
with Jimmie Johnson was there
they sent a scout to his house with the
cowboy hat and everything ready to put
him on them the Dallas Cowboys gonna
select Michael strand with a 30th pick
and all sudden the guy Scouts phone
rings and on the TV they said Dallas
Cowboys have just traded the pick and
stray and turn around the guy was gone
so he was like oh I'm definitely Dallas
come that's somebody in his house and he
was all sudden but he's not a Dallas
Cowboys so the point is yes is everybody
who tells you for everybody says for
months who they take in who they
selected I'm telling you how much it
changes the morning of the day of and I
want a best guess based on your what do
you think what Cleveland's gonna do I'm
what I would do is I would know I'll
tell you what I would do and I don't I
don't like guessing is I like to be
accurate that's right I'm do mock trial
I know who mocked your ass because I'm
knocking a lot of everything that's
going on right now until Monday or
Tuesday what do you think the Browns I
think they should do yes I think the
cleanest guy in the straps is Barkley oh
my god he is a dream come true he shines
he he has so much more to go not I'm
backing them one overall when they need
to say I mean I know they know I must
say no take quarterbacks also but look
like four nights Hillary's 30 look good
no but I'm time I saying don't take a QB
okay you're saying number one this is
what I would do
he still got another draft pick they got
a ton of draft picks I'm not saying I'm
just saying with that pick the the
cleanest guy in this draft
what I think changes the entire identity
of your team is Berkeley like fournette
did last year right with all sudden
Zeile two years ago Zeek two years
before that for years teams like out we
don't have to really focus on a running
back and now it's starting to come back
where they're gonna change the identity
of a team Berkeley is Berkeley still had
like he's so damn fast and quick and he
he doesn't run as many people over and
go after that violence like he should
yet when he starts learning that it
starts learning some Pro stuff it's
gonna be this guy's Hall of Fame
talented he is I've said it about guys
in the past he's the type of guy you
want marrying your daughter leading your
prayer service and leading your team all
300 feet and then running the football
oh man he is yeah and so who's the
cleanest quarterback in this regard I
don't know if there's a cleanest
quarterback in there never is um
I look I there's something I never one
of them right so Sam Donald you gonna
look at and go oh my gosh he you know
his offense through interception boy
through a lot interception sis
cuz he was forcing stuff in but man that
kid when when things are flying he is he
really knows that he's terrific Josh
I've worked with Josh Forrest jars
there's two of them Josh Rosen okay Josh
the stuff that he says kind of makes you
not really know who he really is as far
as like he is way tougher than people
think he is yes he is football makeup is
way better than people are really giving
him credit for
he actually almost stayed in you see I
was very impressed he said hey it was at
the Troy Aikman talked to him he's like
I really it's gonna bother me if I don't
leave a legacy and it was very genuine
and I think that would kind of surprise
people he's also played with a tough
injury ton of injuries I'm thinking that
would surprise people but then it'll say
stuff and I'll be like oh no don't say
that they just it's yes Adama don't say
that in a while though right I said in a
while but what just is one team to fall
in love with him right bear show a lot
of the true Biscay last year all the way
up there you see the one team to fall in
love if God didn't go to the
I don't know where he would have gone so
what's that one team he thinks he's
fallen off odd Rosen what's that one
team I know if I'm if I'm a jet to go
for him like he's actually playing wise
he's cleaner than everybody else just
playing wise his release Technic oh man
he's ridiculous hey dude I
I would I would bet my team on banker
Mitchell absolutely you would this whole
business that he didn't study a playbook
against when he's gonna when he was
gonna interview with the Chargers he
admitted I didn't study the playbook I
think the latest red flag that's nice
he's never shirt on on Sports
Illustrated cover that he's in love with
himself
IIIi don't I don't by the way I put zero
stuff on any of that what the stock I
put in is that he's a guy who put that
flag in the middle of the Illinois State
yep which I don't have a problem with
nope
because they did the same thing to him
lat the year before that have a problem
getting triggered by Kansas just harness
it
harness it know know who your opponent
is know what they're trying to do to you
and don't don't do that got no problem
you don't be triggered by Kansas no I
got a problem with how competitive he is
he has a chip on his shoulder with
everything he's done he has been a guy
like you can tell me I can't okay I'm
gonna surpass it I love it that's who I
want
now look mind you provide that he out
works the world Johnny came into the
league and he was like I'm talented
enough anybody who thinks the talent is
what gets you by in the NFL is an idiot
right any of these players and you've
got to spend you know I tell the story
all that years ago I'm with Sean Payton
down in New Orleans of Thursday night
it's like eleven o'clock and Sean
forgets something back to the office
which you know it's like 40 minutes away
oh dude you're killing me so we got and
he's killing my social life yeah we
drive all the way back to the same
facility and there's one light on in the
facility and it's drew Brees and I'm
like what are you doing here
you know drew has that no thing he's
like sometimes trying to be great is
lonely how that's what he said I'm so
stealing that that deadline that is
great and that's what it is though it's
like out work in the world you do not
get by on talents and all these guys
think
when they come in here I'm talented
enough and they wonder why it's not
working for them and they think
something eventually gonna click you
don't think there's a problem with any
that they all want they all have that
one or not be lonely
Oh what's up do you think they all have
that wanting to be lonely no no no I
don't think that I think a lot of more
come in here you know and a lot of it is
who you're gonna learn from who you're
gonna be around right what your
environment is so I can't answer the
question until they get around certain
coaches that they're gonna connect with
right certain teammates that are sitting
next to her locker what their social
life you don't know Jay Glazer here on
the Rich Eisen show doing a fantastic
job telling us absolutely nothing
specific but being great with the
storytelling you're like Twitter you
want me to tips right I'm gonna do it no
actually no as you know I don't want to
do that I saw you got a fire I want to
hit that with you but I'm just as you
know pulling your leg because we really
don't know anything right now I do I'm
just not gonna you do all right and I do
want to hit vets and players daughter
with you before you before you you uh
vamoose here on the show and we also
have still to come a news update from
Chris Brockman your phone calls at 844
204 rich if you miss John Tortorella
after the Columbus Blue Jackets lost to
the Capitals who are come back and
coming back from the dead if you missed
that don't miss the news segment coming
up here on the rich eyes he should not
sweat out here oh your ball too and
Jewish like me I am we both should be
sweating I don't know but I just you
have the jacket on are you killing me
here Oh Gina alright so we're gonna do
we're gonna take a break down somebody
mopped down Jake when we come back
alright glaze do you want to make a
decision on the jacket here or order you
tried to undress me right now I'm not
going on I'm not rich would you like me
to think to track it off I want you to
do whatever is coming after me rituals
was a good natural writer ladies and
gentlemen Jay Glazer doing runway on the
Rich Eisen show car like that rich I do
that is drug collection right there are
you sighs stray ankle doesn't have them
on it's all luggage huh shoe right here
it's like $42,000 strange perfume
Strahan University beautiful it's
tremendous
I think strands that really Street let
me see yes I think he plays like that
look at the lining don't stretch it too
much that rich what is happening that
Michael Strahan can offer Jay Glazer
[Laughter]
right back with Jay Glazer who's part of
the NFL Network Fox coverage of the 2018
NFL Draft doing coverage of Bellator and
of course the NFL insider of Fox NFL
Sunday you're part of the ESPN NFL
Network Fox CBS I would imagine joint
agreement to not tweet out pics during
the draft first-round correct no here's
the thing for years people always say
this I don't work for Twitter so why
would I put it on Twitter for I don't
tweet it out now Fox Sports Radio where
I've always done the first round right I
will try and give bring people in and
give them more insight there anywhere
else you can get right but I don't tweet
out hey if Twitter is paying me I may
change my mom but they're not so I don't
and that's it it's pretty simple but the
sense of what people who tweet out are
saying that they're doing their jobs and
using the platform that they've created
it for themselves to reach their their
fan base or reach their viewers
listeners readers right I think the fans
have spoken they don't like
I think it's it used to be like hey it
was it was one of his split I think
there's more people come now we want to
know first but they've done such a good
job you know changing the way people
view it then I went 50/50 now it's the
other way of don't we don't want to know
we don't want to read it on Twitter we
want to it really is such a great soap
opera that unfolds live people want to
know it but look I will tell you before
8:00 I'll tell you beforehand when I'm
hearing things are working or I know
somebody likes somebody or doesn't know
I'll be pretty specific about it and why
so that's difference of just tipping a
pit boss say look they have this pick
coming up here I know they love these
three players lease to like a couple
years ago Dallas Cowboys are on the
clock even before they're on the clock I
said as of that morning they were still
going back and forth first it was
Ezekiel Elliott [ __ ] and Ramsey then
it was Ezekiel Elliott and Bosa and then
it went down to Zeke right when they're
on right right before they're on the
clock right somebody will give you this
inside information that there it really
went down they're arguing about it in
the room an hour beforehand and they go
with Zeke and I can kind of back loaded
with even more information I think
that's what you want to do for the fence
really take it behind closed doors well
in terms of that look you know I'm now
seeing on my Twitter feed every 5-10
minutes what I told Jimmy train on his
Sports Illustrated podcast I'm coming at
it from the host of of a televised draft
which I've been fortunate to do every
pic of a televised draft on the NFL
Network since 2006 so this is my 13th
time doing it and so I love doing it I
think it is an old school type show that
it cuz it's a show yes and so I don't
like having anybody look at me think
that I know what they already know
because they are assuming I'm also on
social media like them because I'm I'm
active on it and therefore I'm playing
them by giving my thoughts on who's
coming up fully knowing who it is right
so I don't like being thought of that
way so personally I'm not a fan of it
because I don't look at it mike Mayock
and i
Syst we're not to be told about it but
even more importantly than that I don't
want this format to be big-footed
because it's no longer the most
immediate way to inform used to be the
infirm the Commissioner was the Paul
Revere telling you that the British were
coming by announcing the pic all right
that's not the case anymore sometimes
where we're waiting to announce pick
five and pick nine is on the clock right
now
there's three in the chute that we
haven't announced yet I just don't want
to see this format made antiquated but I
think there's not many who do tip
anymore and I think everybody is in this
case we did kind of listen the fans
their fans are at least the feedback I
get well what do you think about the
response from from reporters saying if
you don't want the picks tip then get
off for Twitter then don't go on that's
their look that's the way they view it
also like I have a different way of
viewing things than most reporters you
know that for a long time right I don't
know if I would have agree with this
several years ago but I'm I know what
the fans want I my opinion what they
want is they want it they don't want a
tip so but again it's if Fox said to me
we want you to do it I'm gonna do it if
Fox said we don't want you to do it I'm
not gonna do it I'm out dummy I'm gonna
tip him on tinder though if you're on
that let's talk merging veteran players
here what an incredible incredible
program you have started thank you my
friend
- you have combat veterans and
professional athletes who are both
transitioning out of careers or back
into civilian life to learn from each
other right yeah yeah what are the new
team what have you gleaned from from
this program that people can get learn
more about it vets and players org my
gosh every week I learned something from
these people this is my new team it's
it's incredible it's interesting because
you know the fight world you're proud of
your scars right your pride your
cauliflower year you're proud of all the
wars you went through but afterwards in
football and then real fighting you're
not and we're trying to get our veterans
in amount of football players to be
proud of everything they went through
after
that includes concussions head injury
anything because that's her only choice
be proud of what you've been through it
you know we had we did one in Chicago
the other day thanks to bell tower
empowerment Network they're the sponsor
want to open up in Chicago and we had
your guy talk see there guys like Olin
Kreutz and big cat Williams but Zach
Miller Kim who obviously almost lost his
leg and we had a veteran there in him
Kirsty Ennis I think you met with me
last year yes who is lost her leg who
shot down Afghanistan is a door gunner
and just you know those two linking up
together now they're gonna go help out
other people who have needed it you're
given we're giving them a new mission or
give them a new team the problem is when
the uniform comes off and you're alone
man that is not good so I'm just trying
to it just made so much sense for me
like damn let's just get a new team so
every single week we're merging in LA
Vegas now hopefully continuing Chicago
and we're trying to get funding
throughout the country
we're give them a little workout just to
get a burn again just to write him that
burn together then we sit around these
wrestle mats after in the ring or
whoever you are after and we talk about
life we talk about well I get a value
your life why we shouldn't kill
ourselves why you need to be of service
to other people why you're not alone and
don't look good look at it like you're
alone and man you've got a lot of value
to the outside world they are you know
they're both played they've both been on
teams and we need them to be proud
individually of what they've done so
they kind of empower power the rest of
the world madam I'm so proud of it you
should be thank you
I'm sure man this is you know you've
inspired so many people in our industry
to make a difference seriously Thank You
Man appreciate it because if you know if
you can bring these folks together like
this using your platform then then why
shouldn't to all of us right I mean
you've been a you've been a leader in
this I mean it I appreciate that you
know what you've done with vets and
players org is the name of the website
emerging vets and players just because
you come across all these folks you know
I it's incredible they put the elephant
in the room and the stuff they talk
about is
it's unlike anything forget movies and
TV it's so start but they need to talk
and again we're there the other day in
Olin Kreutz and big cat and Zach to go
oh my god
I say yep this is my team now this is my
team and should be your team also and
that's what these guys are saying yeah
it it's the worst thing I've leaving you
know leaving football and leaving the
military you suddenly don't have that
team you need that Brotherhood again
we're giving that brother it again well
I'll see you in Dallas sir love it buddy
I'll bring you a Michael Strahan
collection suit will you do that yep
it's not gonna fit you he's promised me
he's gonna get me on the $20,000 pyramid
over and over again and it's yet to
happen good to see you glaze your mouth
will see it you bet we shall see you in
Dallas the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience